good morning everybody my name is
councillor Julie goody and I'm chairman
of the licensing and appeals committee
the other members please introduce
yourself come sure and the committee's
legal adviser today is mr. Chris Owen
just going to run through the emergency
evacuation procedures should we be
required to evacuate the building would
you please leave the building by the
nearest available exit to the chambers
our assembly point will be in the public
carpark at the side of the Civic's way
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect any belongings and do not return
to the building until given permission
to do so by council staff please note
that this meeting will be audio recorded
and can also remind you to switch off
your mobile phones or turn them to
silent thank you
before we start can everybody present
make sure they've switched off their
phones
the committee will follow the procedures
set out and the procedural notice at
item 3 on the agenda the purpose of this
hearing today is to consider an
application for a temporary event notice
made by a crafty crop crop crafts I
would like to remind all parties that
this appeal is not open to the public
anything discussed remains private and
confidential please could the applicant
introduce himself
do you have any witnesses to call mr.
Smith please could the council's
licensing officer introduce himself good
morning I'm Stephen greener I'm the
licensing officer for the ruptured
district and please could be responsible
Authority introduce himself good morning
my name is John Sheridan Rochford
district council environmental health
news gents pink rots with district
council environmental health do you have
any witnesses you wish to call now have
all parties received the agenda and
report of today's hearing please could
all parties be reminded that each have
15 minutes to present their case could
mr. greener summarize the application
good morning this is a temporary event
notice application made under Section
100 of the licensing Act the issuing and
the determination of this hearing must
be in accordance with paragraph 26 one
of the licensing Act 2003 hearings
regulations 2005 and section 105
paragraph 4 of the licensing Act 2003 an
application was submitted by mr. John
Smith using the electronic government
portal on the 28th of November 2019 the
application was received and passed to
Essex Police licensing team and watcher
discounsel Environmental Health Team on
the 28th from November with a
consultation deadline of the 3rd of
December 2019
in summary the application is to extend
the existing license for activities
within the premises known as crafty
casks 33 Eastwood Road Raley Essex
postcode ss6 7jd the premises already
holds a premises license
and license number RDC 19 double O 2 1 5
oblique la PR e where the licensable
activity on the premises license as it
stands allows the sale of alcohol only
between the hours of 12 o'clock
lunchtime until twenty three thirty
hours Monday to Sunday a copy of the
premises license application of the
premises license is attached as Appendix
B
the temporary event application is to
extend the existing licenses of all
stated are broken down by two parts one
which relates to regulated entertainment
which is from eleven o'clock through to
one o'clock and for the sale of alcohol
from 11:30 until one o'clock in the
morning the reason why I've broken that
down is because under the live music
deregulation providing you have an
alcohol premises license you do not need
to have regulate entertainment of
recorded or live music on your license
up to eleven o'clock so that's why it's
been broken down into the two the
application is for up to a hundred
persons to be present in the premises at
any one time
under the representations no
representations was made by Essex police
and an objection notice was received by
the environment of health team on the
grounds that the use of the premises in
accordance with the temporary event
notice would undermined the public and
nuisance objective of the Act a copy of
the objection notice is attached under
Appendix C all parties have been served
with the relevant notices and
documentation and the rights of the
people to attend the hearing and to be
represented under the legal implications
we refer to the licensing acts 2003 the
licensing acts - first of three hearings
regulations 2005 and the guidance issued
under Section 1 h2o for the license X
and finally the statement of licensing
policy approved by full Council for the
of January 2005 - sorry that should is
the incorrect dates that should be 2008
16 to 2021 so please accept my apologies
for that under paragraph 6.1 the
licensing authority must serve any
notices required under section 105 of
the licensing Act of 2003 at least 24
hours before the beginning of the event
the recommendation before the committee
is where the subcommittee supports the
representation from environmental health
and considers it necessary to give the
counter notice for the promotion of the
public nuisance objective give the
premises user and Roger District Council
in fine which helps the Environmental
Health Team accounting notice and a
notice stating the reasons for their
decision where the subcommittee does not
support the representation and does not
consider it necessary to give the
counter notice for the promotion of
public nuisance objective give the
premises user and Roger district council
environmental health team and notice of
their decision and our notice stating
their reasons and that concludes the
report Thank You mr. green just for
clarification can you assure us the
hundred people that you've mentioned has
that been passed by the authorities the
amount of people for that premises
thank you now
thank you do any of my colleagues have
nothing
can I ask there are complaints regarding
noise from these premises can we have
more detail of those place okay
do any other parties have any questions
on what mr. green has said
can I ask the responsible authority to
represent their submissions please okay
thank you and so just to give you an
some background in regards to why we've
arrived at today's hearing and so crafty
cast is a licensed premises and the
premises is located at 33 East Wood Road
it has residential premises directly
above and to the side and obviously
surrounding properties in the area the
premises was granted planning permission
for change of view so it hasn't always
been a licensed premises and conditions
at the time of granting that payment
planning application one of the
conditions was prior to the use of the
building the envelope of the building so
it'd be insulated against the egress of
internally generated noise and the
purpose of this condition is to ensure
the development does not have a
detrimental impact on the occupiers of
the neighboring properties and in terms
of noise unfortunately these works have
not been undertaken and whilst mr. Smith
has had sound installation tests at the
premises this only demonstrates that the
ceiling of the premises attenuate 65 DB
and that no consideration has actually
been taken in in regards to the
transmission and noise through Frankie
more so the outside walls so I'm no
testing has been undertaken in regards
to other ways that noise can be
transmitted to nearby residential
premises and the premises open to the
general public around the end of October
beginning of November and then I first
received my first complaints on the 4th
of November so and the premises had you
know relatively newly opened and
received a number of complaints from
five separate complainants typically
after the license holder had had live
music events at the premises I visited
mr. Smith at the premises on Thursday
the 21st of November to discuss the
nature of the complaint and then emailed
mr. Smith on Thursday the 26th November
to advise them again that I'm continuing
to receive noise complaints and that
noise monitoring would be undertaken so
on Saturday the third
if November I visited one of the
complainants property as I was
anticipating the licensed premises was
going to have music but this was not the
case at the time I'm others it all zone
young no music could be heard playing in
the bar I could hear muffled voices of
the patrons in the busy bar below within
the complainants property I revisited
the complainants again on Wednesday the
4th of December as the premises was
advertising an open mic night which I
anticipated given the nature of the
event may give rise to a noise
unreasonable noise levels within the
complainants property monitoring was
undertaken and amplified music and
amplify voices could be heard within the
complainants property and noise
abatement notice I was subsequently
served following that visit given the
tens is for New Year's Eve I do not feel
that the license holder would be able to
fulfill the licensing objectives in
regards to public nuisance and for this
reason environmental health have
objected to the tens thank you these
properties have you put a lot noisier
material to see the level of to find out
exactly the level of the noise that's
coming through I haven't put in a noise
meter at this stage in regards to such
nuisance and it's based on the average
person so it's a subjective test by an
officer and I say it just reinforces the
planning conditions as well that are
required in regards to unreasonable
interference with the material enjoyment
of somebody's property so it's safe
steady nuisance is a subjective test
it's not set by a decibel level thank
you
the residents are they immediately above
these premises or is there a further
level between is there obviously without
disclosing who the complainants are
which would be unfair on the
there are a number of components that
have complied at various levels in the
vicinity of the the building
so there's five that the authority of
said for starters actual evidence of
these complaints or or they just
telephone calls the complainants have
contacted and me well they've obviously
been in contact with a local counselor
and the advice given to the local
counselor was for them to contact me
director of the complaint people can be
affected in different ways that depend
on how they use their property the
amount of time they spend at the
property so somebody you know may work
nights and not necessarily be affected
by the noise however somebody may be and
they're sort of on a more frequent basis
so the effect may be different so and
that's why it was necessary for me to
speak to the complainants on an
individual basis to assess in regards to
who's most likely to be affected and
reasonably from the noise in order for
me to make the most appropriate visit so
the most appropriate premises in regards
to monitoring the complaints are they
for mostly to evening times I'm just
trying to assess the time was that the
complaints are regarding no so all the
components that were spoken to generally
they follow on from where there's been
live music at the premises in regards to
where R obviously they've had singers or
amplified music at the premises but
obviously one of my components is more
effective than others in regards to you
can hear the noise directly from the bar
but predominantly the majority of the
complaints have followed on from where
they've been in live music event
influences evenings so evenings I take
it the live music
do do we know if the live music is once
a week or is it every night so according
to the complainant its most Fridays and
Saturday nights but also the use of the
premises has increased in regards to
they now from my understanding have open
mic nights because they don't have
regulated entertainment and they benefit
from the deregulation of the live music
outs they can have music Monday through
Sunday from 8:00 in the morning through
to 11 o'clock at night without obviously
having to notify the local authority so
it's that ability that they've got in
order to have music at the premises
thank you could the applicant please
provide the submissions that you have
okay do I'm sorry before I just move on
do any of the other parties have any
questions
accomplish when you visit John on the
wedding day you found that the noise was
excessive I take it did you find the
noise of his excessive
we because of the light the live music
and the amplified speech okay
on the on the Saturday you visited did
you find that none of the noise was
excessive but when we didn't have the
live music yeah
it was on Facebook
right
I mean because you didn't measure things
it's impossible you decide you have
question yes sorry I'm sorry
yeah you when it's your time for
presentation you can then go and say
that but if you have any questions
please raise questions okay no that
that's all I wanted no further questions
do any of the other members have
anything no there's any other party wish
to clarify anything
okay can I ask mr. Smith to make your
submissions there please okay as far as
the planning aspect is can I talk about
the planning aspect if it's relevant to
this change license I made an
application for the discharge of the
planning conditions on the 3rd of
September and I was supposed to get a
decision within eight weeks it's now
been more than 14 weeks and I haven't
heard anything I believed that my
proposal was a good one the only
guidance I was given from planning they
referred me to the Building Regulations
Part A which says that for a conversion
the attenuation should be greater than
43 decibels
now I had some so that I had a starting
position to work from I had some tests
carried out and it was found that the
noise attenuation was 65 decibels which
is more than 20 DBS
above the building regulations the
figure of 20 decibels is a logarithmic
figure which means that we actually
stopped more than a hundred times the
noise power than is required by the
regulations right although I did hear
that there had been some complaints I
haven't received any complaints from my
neighbors either in person or in writing
the
I had a visit from Siobhan Sheridan
saying that there had been complaints I
was surprised because I felt that the
noise attenuation of the building was
excellent and I I agreed with her that I
wouldn't make any changes to what we
were doing so as not to interfere with
her tests because there's no point me
being quiet while she does the tests and
then be it so on her subsequent visit
she said that she found the the noise
was excessive
so I've immediately stopped any live
music
I've even removed our our little PA I
[Music]
believe we have a good
[Music]
I believe our customers crafty castes
are very good we have a mixed age group
mixed genders they have well behaved
generally over 35 and upwards
they're not really people they like they
enjoyed the live music but that's that's
gone but they still they still come to
the pub and the live music is not
necessary for a bit for for our business
it's not our core business core business
is selling craft beers and all our caste
call our caste berries locally produced
and it goes down very well without our
customers and that's their main reason
for coming there the music was really if
you like a thank you to our customers
and but we don't need it so that that
has stopped as far as New Year's Eve is
concerned I have
a license finishes at 11:30 and I really
don't know what to do with my customers
at 11:30 on New Year's Eve I don't feel
that I can ask them to leave at 5 to 12
or 10 to 12 I I think it would be much
better to have them see in the New Year
in in a controlled situation rather than
out on the strip I mean I don't know
what they're going to do if I tell them
they have to leave so but I would like
to withdraw the application for music
but I won't be doing it but I would
still like to be able to stay open and
until a reasonable time on New Year's
Eve it doesn't have to be one o'clock
12:30 would would be fine but I think it
would be a better solution then closing
just before midnight
I think that
it would be very unfortunate for my
customers it probably doesn't make much
difference to me I'm not going to sell
much in the last hour but I think we
provide a good service to the community
and I'd like the opportunity to do that
but thank you thank you
they said earlier that you were asked to
put in insulation but you haven't done
so oh I was asked to put in a plan for
sound insulation at that time this was
done without any knowledge of the
existing obviously any building has some
sound insulation by virtue of of being
the building I felt that because the
building already had what I considered
to be excellent sound insulation where
my application suggested that no further
insulation was required and I'm still
waiting for a decision on that the only
guidance I had was the building
regulations and we were far in excess of
that now
because it's subsequently been found
that the live music has caused a
nuisance I've removed the source of that
nuisance and the the the planning side
is an on is an ongoing thing and I'm
waiting for planning to get back to me
in in fact because they've taken so long
I'm there and entitled to my feedback
because they've exceeded the the eight
weeks I believe that I've done all that
I can I've put a put a plan in place and
that plan hasn't been accepted or
rejected yet and I've tried to cooperate
fully with all the authorities at every
stage but I've I feel that perhaps
planning should do their bit as well if
if they're if they're not satisfied with
my proposal that they they should tell
me what they want I mean I have put a
plan in place which says the insulation
is adequate as it transpires it's not
adequate for live music so I've stopped
it
does any other party wish to clarify
anything yes please and so just in
regards while we're here in regards to
the licensing objectives obviously we're
objecting on the reasons for public
nuisance although an abatement notice
was served in regards to news even the
type of event it is most people at the
stroke of midnight will break into song
in regards to old length I or something
like that and that is part of the public
nuisance objection that obviously aside
from that a special section nuisance
abatement notice has been served part of
the public nuisance is that mr. Smith
has already said that he doesn't know
how he's going to control the premises
in regards to people leaving it if
pertains isn't granted our concerns were
being because how he's going to control
the premises at midnight with people
breaking into song in regards to trying
to fulfill the licensing objective in
regards to public nuisance thank you
I agree that it's probably quite likely
that people will sing auld lang syne at
midnight whether they're in my premises
or outside along with everybody else in
the world
it's
[Music]
I think a chorus of auld lang syne at
midnight on New Year's Eve is not
unreasonable it's a it's a one-off event
it's not a continuing nuisance it's
something that will probably last a few
minutes and I'm sure there'll be lots of
fireworks going on at midnight I'm I'm
sure there will be people honking their
horns it
whatever happens in crafty casks Raley
High Street will not be quiet at
midnight on New Year's Eve maybe it will
be but that's my opinion I don't think
we will be adding significantly to the
noise nuisance on New Year's Eve at
midnight Thank You mr. Smith do you have
any closing statement for to me I think
that's about it thank you do any other
parties have any closing statements so
it was just one issue in regards to and
mr. Smith said about everybody
celebrating not everybody celebrates New
Year when regards to when you live in a
licensed premises there is that
expectation in regards to atmosphere
however in regards to local residents
some people are people with very young
families elderly and they don't all see
in the new year in the same way that you
would be expected to have in a licensed
premises if it's relevant yes yeah the
point I was trying to make is that
although we will be making some noise I
don't believe we'll be adding
significantly to the noise that will be
around at that time in any case
thank you the committee will now adjourn
for 30 minutes to consider the case and
the decision you do not have to wait but
you are welcome to do so and the
decision will be sent to you in writing
thank you thank you for waiting the
committee has given careful
consideration to the application and all
of the written and verbal evidence
presented including the objection notice
from environmental health
we have heard evidence from
environmental health in respect to five
separate complaints received from
different residents about noise which
started shortly after the premises had
started operating environmental health
visited the premises on the 21st of
November and advised the license holder
that noise complaints had been received
environmental health also made to noise
monitoring visits to one of the
complainants homes and although there
was no excessive noise on the first
visit the second visit on the 4th of
December resulted in the issue of an
abatement notice due to excessive noise
from amplified music on this occasion
excessive noise could be heard from the
residents property the committee have
also heard from the applicant that he
had submitted to the Planning Department
a plan for sound insulation on the third
of September and he was still waiting
for a decision he also advised that he
had received no complaints from
neighbors either in person or in writing
and only knew there were complaints when
the environmental health officer
contacted him he felt the noise
attenuation was good however after a
further visit from environmental health
and the serving of a noise abatement
notice he removed the PA system and had
not had any live music
at the premises since he considered that
his customers were reasonable and would
not cause unnecessary disturbance to
neighboring residents live music was not
the core business which was the cell of
local made craft beers the applicant
stated that he would be willing to
withdraw the element of live amplified
music from the application and would
also be willing to close the premises at
12:30 on New Year's Eve 12:30 a.m. he
accepted that people may be vocal in
their celebrations on New Year's Eve
however he did not feel that his
premises would significantly add to any
noise in the high street the committee
had considered the representation made
by environmental health and commended
the officers for visiting one of the
complainants properties and conducting
noise monitoring on more than one
occasion however the committee does not
feel that a counter notice should be
served in order to promote the public
nuisance licensing objective the
committee considers that the application
with the removal of regulated
entertainment and the closure of the
premises at 12:30 a.m. together with the
conditions in place on the current
premises license will promote the
licensing objective this concludes the
hearing thank you all for attending